just pictures though coming into us from
the scene at the metro station in
Brussels where after ten people
potentially have died this is male beck
metro station in the EU quarter the
explosion there happened around 8 a.m.
UK time a very very busy time on the
metro station this serves that those are
using the EU buildings nearby
it's a busy metro station now the entire
metro network is closed down you can see
the number of injured they're receiving
treatment on the ground we've also seen
footage from inside the metro station of
people walking along the tracks walking
to try to help the injured and walking
away to safety although reminiscent of
the scenes here in London back on the
7th of July all those years ago a very
difficult police operation because a lot
of chaos as you would expect with people
trying to get where they need to but now
that the whole of the transport network
and bristles is in lockdown tubes or the
Metro they're going nowhere buses and
trains also closed on obviously the
airports as well but obviously police
hoping help try to help those who've
been injured